hey I was gonna breastfeed welcome to
France would Peter Pan for this week's
episode I asked you bros to suggest me
what we're gonna do on today's Friday
repair ba and you bros suggested that I
was gonna risk me daddy
so anyways um mommy [ __ ] me you bros
suggested that I was gonna me alright
stop now your daddy I'm pretty sure I'm
not your mommy either not your little
sister not your booty call
I'm not your body massager I'm not your
plumber I'm not I'm not anything weird
like that just just stop please I bought
it go [ __ ] yourself
I I would but your your mom is coming
over someone call for a doctor for that
sick burn up top Yee
all right price please I'm Sam pie
address me as my only Christmas a bottle
you know that's it I'm done fact that I
am done with this I did not become a
youtuber just so teens can tweet at me
[ __ ] me daddy all day who are you
talking to I don't know
all right - my [ __ ] you what oh my god
if you follow me on Twitter we should by
the way all right
PewDiePie then you probably noticed that
anytime I tweet something there's a
bunch of profanity tweeted to me right
away calling me daddy
and all this weird [ __ ] and it's wrong
and y'all need Jesus but anyway you're
Bruce remember Kony 2012 a campaign to
stop Kony while I'm campaigning hashtag
stop daddy 2015 baby
can we stop daddy I think with hashtags
we can do it could hashtag always works
spread the hashtag and we can hopefully
stop daddy but anyway on a completely
different note it was about a month
month ago now since I made my pledge
video where I basically said I'm gonna
actually reply to you Bruce comments and
I've been doing that every single day
it's been very cool I'm so happy I made
this decision I find a lot of more
amazing comments than before and even
though there's so many goddamn tweets
but I also feel like you bros feel like
I'm there as well like I've always read
the comments but now you see me there
and I am there and I've seen that people
write the comments as if the writing to
me and that's I appreciate that it's
very cool it's very personal and I know
I always keep talking about the comments
but it's really my main in waiting track
really bro so it's important to me and I
was stopping hashtag stop what was it
hashtag stop daddy so we can stop these
bad fans who writes bad comments like
damnit so we can stop all these terrible
stupid comments all right Froese damn it
alright here's a I gotta go but here's
the brofist it's only if you are a good
pro not a daddy bro her Jesus Christ
brofist